the next layer in the fake elector scam
is now pushing towards criminality
you have to see this this is
unbelievable
newly obtained surveillance video
shows fake trump elector
escorted operatives
into georgia county's elections office
before
the voting machine breach
let's reset the story
the fake elector scam the fake elector
scam was where there were states won by
joe biden in november of 2020 yes nearly
two years ago they're still going nearly
two years ago in november of 2020 joe
biden won certain states like georgia
and arizona and republicans came up with
the idea
of just sending different electors
to say we cast our ballot we cast our
electoral votes
for donald trump even though trump
didn't win they would claim that he did
we now have footage of a republican and
a republican county official in georgia
who was one of these fake electors
escorting two operatives
working with an attorney for trump
into the county's election offices
on the same day that a voting system
there was breached
understand that these people
breached election systems okay
in the surveillance video
obtained by cnn
kathy latham a former republican
chairwoman of coffey county under
criminal investigation for posing as a
fake elector in 2020
escorted a team of pro-trump
operatives to the election offices on
january 7 2021
that's the same day
that the voting system there was
breached
they are the ones breaching the systems
they are the ones attempting the fraud
here is a report from cnn newly obtained
video to cnn shows a former georgia
republican county official escorting two
operatives hired by an attorney for
former president trump
into the county's election offices on
the same day a voting system there was
illegally breached wow drew griffin has
the details drew what an incredible
coincidence right
breaches of these voting machines guys
and swing states are under investigation
across the country this one happened in
coffey county georgia rural county cnn
obtained surveillance video at one of
the offices where the voting machines
were breached and all this at the best
of one of donald trump's attorneys i
want to show you right now this is kathy
latham we're showing you she's the
former chairwoman of coffee county gop
already under investigation this woman
is for posing as one of those fake
electors who signed documents that
declared donald trump was the winner of
the 2020 election latham can be seen
here escorting a team of pro-trump
operatives into the coffee county
elections office including an i.t
specialist who was working with trump
attorney sydney powell this all happens
on the same day the vote can you imagine
they have so many conspiracy theories
they were the ones conspiring look at
this voting system in that office was
illegally breached january 7 2021 the
day after the attack on the u.s capitol
text messages emails and witness
testimony from a civil lawsuit against
georgia election officials have
connected latham that woman to the plan
to give the group access to the
elections office
about a week before this voting machine
breach that same woman latham testified
before the georgia state legislature
along with rudy giuliani talking all
about voter machine irregularities in
coffee county latham's attorney told cnn
seems some of the irregularities were
latham herself giving people who
shouldn't have access to the voting
systems access to the voting systems is
anybody ever going to jail for trying to
steal the 2020 election for trump while
they were screaming election fraud
mail-in ballot fraud democratic fraud
for months
they tried to steal it they did it in
this particular case in broad daylight
daylight if you didn't see the video
it's the middle of the day when they
show up
and
i'm sure that some of them would say
we had to do this stuff because the
democrats cheated
the democrats were cheating so bad that
we had to do it this way but
you all in my audience
didn't fall for it when trump started
with this stuff late spring early summer
2020.
when trump started saying they're gonna
rig it this way they're gonna rig it
that way it's all insecure
many of you dozens and dozens of you
wrote to me and said david allegations
or confessions with these people
trump's saying he's going to try to
steal it that's what trump is saying and
of course you were all completely
correct incredible
people better start landing in prison
for this they really should and we're
going to follow that and as charges
develop
and hopefully they will
we will tell you whether people are
actually being held accountable
one of our longtime sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you 50 dollars off as
many of you know i am not vegetarian but
i think eating plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now whether you're
vegan or you just want to add an easy
delicious way to have more plants in
your diet splendid spoon is a great way
to go there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates constantly i've tried a lot of
different meal subscription services
splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when i'm on the go and you'll
get fifty dollars off your first week
when you subscribe at splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below